retrouvons notre envoyé spécial à
kharkhiv romeo langlois romeo bonjour
vous avez réalisé un reportage sur la
vie sous les bombes comment s'organise t
elle
eh bien écoutez vous l'avais dit après
le porte de mario paul rasé quasiment
par l'artillerie de la lumière poutine
car qui vais probablement la ville la
pub bombardé au monde alors ici les
explosions sont permanentes il ya eu
plus de 300 morts probablement beaucoup
de plus depuis le début du conflit il y
à un mois et demi et les gens
s'habituent à vivre au rythme des
explosions alors bien sûr dans les
quartiers nord de la ville qui sont des
spectacle de désolation
eh bien ces quartiers les gens ont fui
une
infime minorité de personnes vivent
encore chez elle la plupart se terre
dans des caves mais la plupart des gens
sont partis loin de karkhiv ou alors ils
s'entassent dans le métro ou une
véritable vie souterraine est en train
de se développer mais dans le reste de
la ville il faut savoir que les frappes
peuvent peuvent toucher tout à n'importe
quel moment n'importe quel endroit et à
n'importe quel moment et bien dans le
reste de la ville les gens essaient
malgré tout de continuer à avoir une vie
normale dans la mesure où c'est possible
puisque évidemment tous les magasins
sont fermés les restaurants bien sûr
évidemment ne sont ouvertes que quelques
stations service et quelques
supermarchés dans lesquelles les gens se
ravitaillent avant de rentrer et
cuisiner chez eux alors bien sûr il n'y
a pas grand monde dans les rues alors
bien sûr les gens de temps en temps
sorte pour prendre l'air mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est que essaie malgré tout de
s'habituer à cette situation grande
partie des habitants par exemple
continue en tout cas certains d'entre
eux à vivre dans leur appartement ils ne
dorment pas nécessairement tous dans des
refuges dans le reste de la ville j'ai
discuté hier par exemple avec un
ambulancier qui lui vit au 9e étage d'un
appartement et qui nous confiait il ya
plusieurs jours avoir eu la peur de sa
vie lorsqu'il ya du deux missiles russes
passé juste devant sa fenêtre alors
justement pour donner un exemple avec un
autre ambulanciers nous sommes fière
parti pour porter secours ils sont allés
soigner les blessures d'un homme qui
venait juste de subir une frappe à côté
de sa résidence étaient des blessures
très légères des éclats de verre qui
avait blessé à la main qu'il avait un
petit peu blessé à la tête cet homme
avait ses valises qui étaient prêtes
nous pensions qu'ils allaient partir et
nous expliquer non lui il va rester chez
lui il y avait fait ses valises pour
pouvoir venir quelques jours dans le
refuge dans la terre dans la cave dans
laquelle il se taire sous son immeuble
chaque fois qu'il y à une explosion le
l'histoire de ces ambulanciers
d'histoire de cet homme de se blesser
qui refuse de quitter sa ville il est à
l'image du de tous les hommes de du
courage et de la résilience de tous ces
gens de kharkiv qui malgré cette pluie
de bombes permanente tente malgré tout
de résister de rester et d'essayer de
survivre et d'avoir une vie normale
bonjour romeo kharkiv est dans second
est une craignant sur lequel les forces
russes se concentrent à présent de façon
assumée quelle est la situation
militaire autour de là où vous vous
trouvez
alors autour de la ville de kharkiv qui
est la deuxième ville du pays qui
comptait un million et demi d'habitants
avant la guerre on estime que entre 30
et 50% de la population auraient fui
alors autour la ville de kharkiv les
forces russes en périphérie avant se
peut la situation est relativement
stable alors certes il ya eu ces
bombardements permanent mais les gens
sont encore là et les russes n'avance
pas encore en région en revanche dans
tout le reste de la région de l'oblast
de karkhiv la situation est beaucoup
plus critique notamment autour de la
localité 10 um au sud-est de kharkiv en
direction du donbass ici les troupes
russes avancent elles à elles ont réussi
à prendre donc la localité elles ont
rasé une localité proche qui s'appelle
ballack l'ia dans laquelle environ selon
le maire de batz la quille à 80 % des
immeubles et des maisons d'habitations
ont été détruites donc dans une grande
partie de la région de kharkiv qui est
évidemment fait de petites villes
beaucoup plus difficile à défendre deux
terrains découverts ou l'artillerie
russe tourne à plein régime et bien dans
ces zones la situation est beaucoup plus
critique
une grande partie de ces régions honte
ont reçu un ordre d'évacuation ce n'est
pas le cas à kharkiv vous l'avez dit le
maire a dit que la ville était prête à
se défendre que la ville était bien
armée et que les gens pouvaient rester
mais dans toutes les zones rurales et
notamment dans les autres provinces de
l'est de l'ukraine la situation est
beaucoup plus complexe là c'est
désormais l'exode les gens prennent la
voiture prennent le train pour suivre au
plus vite la région